You have two choices
you can be the destroyer of this world
Heroes don't kill people. Well I do.
Welcome back everyone this will be my new black
adam trailer video they released a new one at
the nba finals with a little bit of different
footage so we'll break it all down we also learned
a little bit more about what's going on with
the villains during the movie and how that ties
back to black adam versus the justice league in
black adam versus darkseid and black adam versus
superman pretty much is black adam versus every
major hero inside the dc universe now like this
is just the tip of the iceberg if you smell what
the rock is cooking he is cooking up a giant royal
rumble against the entire dceu now if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos but in the new trailer footage we see
dr fate talking to black adam trying to convince
him to help the justice society stop intergang who
we now know is this main tech based villain here
and the sabac villain who's like the more
supernatural threat the inner gang is trying to
take advantage of inner gang seems like the group
using this advanced looking ship like hawkman has
this advanced stanigarian nth metal ship inner
gang is also using advanced technology but it's
not the exact same technology it just looks
a little bit similar i'll explain where they
would get that from like hogman ship comes from
a completely different race of people that are
way more advanced inner gang's technology comes
with some bargains quote-unquote that they make on
an intergalactic level with some really big dceu
villains like darkseid everybody wondering after
the justice league snyder cut when we're gonna
see darkseid again in the dceu don't worry i'll
talk about him in a second too but the soldiers
putting this person in cryo from 5000 years ago is
inner gang that's what those symbols on all their
arms are on all their bikes are you see the same
symbol on the thugs here in the street when black
adam is doing that hilarious take down just gonna
punt you a couple miles out of the way the figure
that they're putting into cryo here also does look
almost exactly the same as black adam does in the
flashbacks to kondok five thousand plus years ago
but it's not the same figure as swole as he looks
he is not nearly as huge as the rock is but he
has the pendants around his neck he has the same
garbon he has the same wraps around his arms black
adam has the same wraps on his arms when he's
clutching this woman who's crying that's supposed
to be black adam's wife five thousand plus years
ago and it sounds like their son has just died
it's no coincidence that she looks extremely
similar to adriana tomas in present day and that's
sarah shahi's character is one of the reasons why
he develops a connection to her in present day now
she obviously is the person who frees him from his
magical prison that the wizard shazam put him in
so obviously he would feel some kind of connection
to her but she also looks almost exactly like the
wife that he lost five thousand years ago this
younger boy here seems like he's going to be a
surrogate for his young son too like he'll look
similar to black adam's young son or he'll think
of him that way and that's why he wants to protect
them they'll probably be the ones to help convince
him to do the right thing at least temporarily
during this situation with inner gang and the
sabacc villain but it sounds like what inner
gang is trying to do is use this crown in his
tomb which i believe is supposed to be the crown
of sabac to basically give this figure here that
they're putting into cryo the same types of powers
that black adam has and that shazam has so that
they can use subox power to eventually take over
the world sebac is basically like a magic based
shazam villain but he's a demon instead of being
a god so like shazam gets all these powers from
these gods the same thing happens with sabach he
can grant all of his power to this person on earth
like an avatar but he just happens to be a demon
who's really evil who wants to take over the world
so i think you have this idea that inner gang is
trying to use his power to take over the world
and he's also secretly using them like i will give
you my power to take over the world eventually and
get rid of this black atom figure but i'm also
kind of pulling a double cross on you so that i
can take over the world so i believe that sabac is
really supposed to be the main villain of the film
not just inner gang inner gang is sort of like
the mid-level boss there's also another new scene
inside the hall of justice inside their mansion
or their main base with dr fate sitting around
the main table in their meeting room talking
to the newer younger members adam smasher and
cyclone about what's going on one of the funny
things about him carrying around the helmet of
fate with him isn't so much about him protecting
the powers of dr fader protecting the helmet
of fate it's not that he's trying to prevent
someone else from stealing those powers from him
one of the funny twists of the doctor fake
character is the powers of dr fate are
basically a curse you basically form a contract
with naboo this avatar of the gods of order
he basically winds up taking over your body like
you gain all these powers but for the most part
you're kind of forced to do whatever he wants you
to do and the only way to end the bargain with him
in stopping dr fate is for someone else to take up
the mantle kind of like taking up the curse so dr
fate is trying to prevent other people from being
taken by that like no no you don't want to touch
this you don't want this power it's not good but
talking about black adam versus the justice league
you probably remember the video from a little
while ago where the black animal specifically
puts the justice league all of them on notice this
is the clip of him talking about that but before i
go i want you guys to help me out with something
it's something that's pretty important i need you
guys to help me get a message out to uh to some
of the other ones some of the other dc superheroes
let's let flash shazam aquaman wonder woman batman
and superman let's let them know something things
will never be the same because the hierarchy
of power in the dc universe is about to change
a lot of you now asking why didn't he mention
cyborg when he was challenging the rest of the
justice league there could have been a bunch
of different reasons for that but it is kind
of funny that he did not mention cyborg when
he was doing that but the cool thing is that
zachary levi many times in the past couple years
ever since that first shazam movie has said that
they plan on putting shazam on the next version of
the justice league and now that we have black adam
and they literally just put the entire justice
league on notice like he's going to fight them
all it sounds like black adam is going to be one
of the villains of the next justice league movie
and when i say the next justice league movie
i'm not talking about zack snyder's justice
league 2 in justice league 3. he was originally
going to do a trilogy i did a full breakdown of
the plot of those movies because he basically
revealed all the concept art and the story what
that would be so i'll put a link for that down
in the description below in the next version of
the justice league that we see in the movies will
be completely different from that black adam has
previously been a member of lex luthor's injustice
society and legion of doom now at the end of the
justice league snyder cut he's actually teasing
the injustice league not the injustice society
slightly different organizations but not the
exact same thing like there are a couple main
evil organizations inside the dc eu the whole
connection between black adam and darkseid is
that darkseid usually winds up being the person
controlling intergang through his agents like
assad like inner gang is an intergalactic villain
organization with ties to other planets like
apocalypse and dark side that's where they
get a lot of their advanced technology from
usually darkseid uses inner gang as his pawns
to take over the earth slowly preparing it for
eventual takeover in a more insidious way as a way
to avoid another all-out massive conflict with the
justice league and the other combined superheroes
of earth like the justice society the shazam
family the amazons the atlanteans if he were to
bring his forces back to earth the same thing
would happen again that we saw during the justice
league snyder cup like they would all have an
all-out war with him again so in the comics he has
all kinds of irons in the fire trying all kinds of
different ways to take over the earth playing
four-dimensional chess with the other heroes
inner gang decide is just one of those groups
of characters and if it wasn't clear during the
justice league snyder cut this character here is
meant to be dazad if we're talking about villains
in the black adam movie another big connection
back to the shazam family is that dr savannah was
part of intergang and even though lex luthor led
the team in the comics they might swerve on that
in this movie because they set him up basically as
the leader of the injustice league so they might
just say the inner gang has ties to lex luthor's
organization and gets some of their technology
from him because of course a character like lex
luthor would be funding all kinds of shady stuff
all over the planet but in terms of black adam
versus henry cavill superman separately when
he was calling out the justice league he also
had a separate clip where he was specifically
talking about black adam versus superman this
is the clip of him talking about that you know
i always thought that it might be cool to
hang out with superman that would be cool
right i mean we're kind of similar in terms
of our powers our strengths our speeds because
look at the end of the day you never know
black adam and superman could become friends
or they won't who knows maybe we'll see the funny
thing about that is you may remember a couple
years ago before they officially announced
the film before there was ever a trailer or
anything like that the rock sounds like he'd been
pitching a version of the movie to warner brothers
executives about him versus henry cavill superman
instead of against inner gang with the justice
society because a couple years ago before the film
actually materialized before they started filming
it he actually commissioned some special art from
boss logic specifically with him fighting henry
cavill superman it sounds like he did some of that
just to pitch the idea to warner bros executives
like wouldn't it be cool if we saw a black adam
versus superman movie why don't we do that i think
the main reason why they didn't start out with
black adam being a superman movie like black adam
versus superman is because of what was going on
with henry cavill superman inside warner brothers
in all the turmoil that was going on between the
buyouts and all the different executives coming
and going and it sounds like they just weren't
sure what the future of henry cavill superman
was going to be but that was a couple years ago
cut to now and it sounds like they're really hot
on bringing him back so the odds of them actually
doing this black adam versus superman encounter
in the movies just shot up like a thousand
percent so if you spotted any other easter
eggs in the footage that i didn't talk about in
my last couple of trailer videos just write them
below in the comments and i will do more black
adam videos as we get more footage we learn
more about what's going on in the movie and him
versus the justice league can't wait to see him
put the beat down on the shazam family and shazam
3 or whatever that winds up being and against the
justice league and whatever that separate movie
winds up being everyone click here for my other
black adam trailer video and click here for my
brand new thor love and thunder trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!